Juan Armando Garcia is Colombia's
biggest drug lord the United States
issued a 25 million-dollar reward out
for the capture of mr. Garcia we got to
go on vacation man likes a vacation from
our lives three tickets have a wonderful
time in that nation of Colombia
to think about it listen 25 million
dollar reward for the capture of this
dude I'm doing it then what have you
done now you don't remember anything you
lost your mind and your wife your job
and your dignity rah
so you somehow thought thinners to a
third world country to catch on
Colombian cartel drug lord is a good
idea
II totally was coming on vacation and I
know we're gonna be doing Rambo she know
they got start man You Know Who I am mr.
Pomeroy tell members kidnapped our
friend we were told that you can help
[Laughter]
what are you doing oh yeah gentlemen
welcome to my training ground first
lesson always be aware of your
surroundings we stayed up all night
painting yourself like your wall
only one thing you need to know to keep
from getting killed back I'm going to
show you lip shut up the Grady yeah come
on darling
[Music]
you